[Music]
and i think
ordinary people are starting to see well
here's an economy where the ordinary
worker is losing their jobs
losing their income and yet stock prices
are doubling trebling
[Music]
i think in reality it's more complicated
than that and there probably are
sophisticated investors on both sides
but people love that story because
people listen especially since the 2008
crisis i've seen it you've seen it
everyone's seen it the rich
stock markets go up and up and up and
ordinary people's wages just flatline on
the floor
and people want to turn people want to
turn the tables
[Music]
so what happens is the government prints
new money they give it to ordinary
people who've lost their jobs and then
ordinary people use it to pay their
bills
and that goes to and to pay their rent
that goes to richer people who own the
assets
and then because richer people cannot
spend in kobe it means the money just
builds up in their bank accounts
i know what rich people do when they
have lots of money they buy stocks they
buy shares they buy property
[Music]
i just want to tell people to be careful
and don't think that
you're gonna become a millionaire from
an internet messaging board because the
truth is
75 of people who gamble stops on the
internet lose money
and you know those who don't are often
professional investors
and don't risk your life savings or
money their family
needs
[Music]
you know the truth is these are guys who
often make money and take advantage of
the regulations as they are
it's a bit rich of them to be calling
for more regulation
we need to start getting the richest
people to contribute to our system
rather than simply taking from it and if
we don't do that if we keep trying to
fix
it by pouring more and more money in we
will get these sort of hugely volatile
stock markets if we really want to make
real change we need to have tax reform
on the wealthiest people who often
we have billionaires paying lower rates
of tax and then they're cleaner
you